bitcoin and leverage are they friends or
are they enemies how do you look at
bitcoin and leverage you've been doing
this for much longer even than i have uh
what's your take on all the leverage in
the system and kind of how we should
expect this to play out
it's bad they're enemies bitcoin doesn't
have
yield inherently so all the all this
yield chasing it that's happened in the
last few years especially uh since the
last four-year bull cycle so really
beginning in 2017 is when the leverage
started coming in and people started to
create financial products with yield on
bitcoin bitcoin itself doesn't have any
yield it doesn't need any yield it's uh
it's its inflation rate right now is
1.75 percent compared to cpi of 8.6
percent so you come out ahead on an
inflation-adjusted basis just by holding
it
and uh of course as you know uh most of
your listeners know that that inflation
rate gets cut in half every two every
four years and we're less than two years
from that inflation rate getting cut in
half from one point seven five percent
now to
point eight eight percent in 2024 and
then point four four percent in 2028 et
cetera
so when you start to think about this
leverage in the system and and uh kind
of uh inflation
my general read is that the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
has i don't know gamified uh financial
markets it's caused very short-term
thinking it's led to this kind of casino
effect not just in stocks but in other
asset classes as well is leverage a
byproduct of that and people basically
are playing a game and so they say if
i'm going to play let me really play and
then that leads to uh so much leverage
being built up
oh absolutely yes this is not unique to
crypto of course crypto just happened to
be
an easy place for folks to do it over
the last few years but yes there's too
much leverage in tradify as well and
just like we don't know how much
leverage there is in the crypto universe
because it's impossible to measure
we don't know how much leverage there is
in tradify as well the euro dollar
market i've done a lot of work for
example with dr singh from the imf
he he's known for
having the best estimates of leverage in
the euro dollar market and there's it's
so much opacity that you don't he he can
only update his estimates once a year
and it's based on year-end financial
statements and we know how much balance
sheet window dressing gets done to
financial institutions balance sheets
right before they do a big annual report
so there's a lot more leverage out there
i think than most folks know and it is a
function of debt being artificially
cheap but as you and i talked yesterday
when we were prepping for this
i think we've had we've undergone a
regime change it was clearly the case
that
that that there was artificially cheap
debt out there and for the last 30
plus years the incentive was to lever up
and buy
assets that were going to go down by
less than the currency was going to go
down in value and i think we may have
already incurred a regime change and
that's why you're seeing a lot of
bankruptcies of companies that played
that game including and especially in
crypto which is kind of leading tradfi
in terms of um in terms of the
correction
so when you start to think about the
last two years you can see that
obviously wall street came in in a major
way uh we saw paul tudor jones we saw
stanley drucker miller two of the you
know widely considered best investors in
the world uh talk about bitcoin as an
inflation hedge in q3 q4 of 2020. there
was no inflation at the time uh or at
least not to the degree that we
eventually saw right and
they went ahead they made the move once
they did that
my
understanding or evaluation is that they
removed all career risk for anyone on
wall street to begin to allocate the
bitcoin so we saw obviously public
companies uh doing it we saw wall street
hedge funds we saw private investors
family offices like it was game on
bitcoin went from ten thousand dollars
uh or so to about sixty thousand dollars
uh by march of uh 2021. and there's a
whole bunch of structural things as to
why that happened including gbtc
arbitrage and many other factors but
there was a financialization it seemed
like that happened in the asset
if we then fast forward a year later
october november even in december of
2021 uh many of those wall street
investors were still holding bitcoin and
the fed changed its tune uh yep and it
seemed like bitcoin's the riskiest asset
in their portfolio and so when they went
risk off bitcoin was you know sent to
the altar and sacrificed uh to some
degree right how do you think about
wall street
hedge funds financial institutions and
bitcoin and like
is it a part of the game and we should
expect it to continue or is it bad and
actually we don't want this to continue
uh it's bad
uh because the leverage games are bad
the long only players that looked at it
as a true inflation hedge have been good
for it but the long only the the the
hedge fund leverage games that's what's
been bad uh and of course it's not
trading it hasn't traded like an
inflation hedge that doesn't mean that
it won't it's just traded as your as you
correctly point out as a more um uh you
know high beta play uh on the industry
right now and uh but you you i'd like to
go back because you mentioned something
that i think is really important which
is the gbtc arb
you got to realize that that was created
by the sec the sec sat for six years
with one and only one way
to
for folks to be able to get exposure in
their brokerage accounts to bitcoin and
that was through the closed-end fund
structure for grayscale gbtc and it took
them six years to to approve a competing
product well you know very well you've
talked about it on your show before the
the structural issues with closed end
funds uh and if they traded premiums
when demand exceeds supply okay now in
that case i went back and looked just to
kind of do a retrospective on this the
premium
more it peaked at more than double the
price of bitcoin at its peak and and it
was pretty consistently a hefty premium
until last year at which point it went
to a discount and last i looked it was
at a 34 discount okay so you've had a
wild roller coaster that has been
rocketed along by the sec because there
was no competing product that could
satisfy that demand and uh and as a
result the premium just went to you know
stratospheric levels okay now um how
does that play into the hedge fund
leverage game that attracted a lot of
hedge funds who wanted to come in to to
play that sure thing trade to capture
that that risk-free arbitrage of
collecting that premium and
again it was at one point at more than
double the price of bitcoin right that's
a hefty premium for a risk-free trade
and what ended up happening is they put
a lot of leverage on and then you they
played the next big thing which was the
contain go in the futures market and you
could go offshore and get 125 to 1
leverage you still can get 20 to 1
leverage very easily offshore not on
shore but but
but offshore uh and then when that
started to collapse where did they go
they went to the anchor protocol which
was a ponzi scheme and when that that
collapsed the whole thing ended up
coming unwound but all of this was
foreseeable because bitcoin itself it
doesn't have a yield and it shouldn't be
leveraged it's incompatible with
leverage and why is that because no
one's ever going to make more than 21
million of these and so
i always credit trace mayor calling
bitcoin the apex predator of finance
there is no one to bail it out and at
some point all this leverage is going to
be flushed out of the market and i think
that's a healthy thing but you got to
realize that some of this leverage was
regulator created